voici le centre névralgique de la
bataille contre le groupe armé état
islamique dans la province de
salaheddine au nord de bagdad
le mans chargé des opérations
c'est le major général juma anad
al-jabouri vous avez ici un commandement
unis la moitié de ce que vous voyez
derrière - font partie de la
mobilisation populaire
nous travaillons ensemble nous
planifions mode à bas débit maintenant
la coalition internationale dont fait
partie le canada maintient qu'elle ne
travaille qu'avec les armées irakiennes
et kurdes plutôt qu'avec les différents
groupes armés qui se sont joints aux
combats et à quelques kilomètres de ses
combats c'est une subtilité qui se perd
la fin justifie les moyens
nous avons un ennemi commun tous sont
bienvenus ici des frappes de la
coalition sont réclamées par tous
groupes confondus
qu'ils soient de la glisse le
commandement retransmet les coordonnées
géographiques des cibles potentielles
pour les ajouter à la liste
ce qui se passe par la suite est à la
discrétion des officiers de la coalition
une grande source de frustration pour le
général dumas arrêts par exemple si on
d'indicible il n'en élimine que deux ou
trois et ils ignorent 17e c'est à n'y
rien comprendre
en 2003 tous les jours il y avait un
millier bombardements milles s'ils
voulaient vraiment nous aider je vous
assure qu'il le peut je leur donne les
cibles mais il n'en fera pas plus de 15%
parfois même ils nous contactent pour
nous dire qu'ils voient un véhicule avec
des hommes armés de da moi je les
supplie de frapper je leur dis que je
suis prêt à prendre l'entière
responsabilité à aller devant les
nations unies au tribunal de l'est aucun
problème mais frappe est belle mais
conséquence dit le général
il faut se montrer patient avec ceux qui
affrontent le groupe armita islamique de
face nous sommes à quelques kilomètres
de la raffinerie de baïji la plus
importante d'irak les forces
gouvernementales et le hic se disputent
le contrôle de l'inestimable sources de
revenus depuis près d'un an
cette mosquée que l'on voit à l'horizon
devrait être bombardée selon le cheikh
aziz
nos hommes ont repoussé l'ennemi et
maintenant il est retranché dans la
mosquée mais la coalition ne veut jamais
frappé les mosquées alors on doit
utiliser l'artillerie ya bien qu'on ne
va rien
une première deuxième et troisième
tentative rate la cible
chaque guide les efforts après une
dizaine de rectification succès le
chéque aziz et ses hommes sont chez eux
ici ils ont dû combattre des voisins des
cousins des frères qui ont prêté
allégeance au groupe etat islamique
après plusieurs batailles entre les
combattants du groupe armé islamique et
les forces qui soutiennent le
gouvernement irakien le village de mizra
libéré mais à quel prix
partout dans le village on ne voit plus
que des bris que bombes artisanales non
explosées et que restes humains mazerat
est pour le moins inhabitables en allant
de maisons détruites en maisons
détruites
il faut prendre garde le village n'a pas
encore été nettoyée des milliers de
traquenard posé par un ennemi battant en
retraite ici
la veste d'un kamikaze ce potentiel a
été laissée derrière par le i encore
bourré d'explosifs
il les porte au combat et quand il tombe
à court de munitions
ils se font exploser devant les forces
de sécurité les corps et autres restes
humains aussi georges toujours le sol
voyez même quand on les enterre ils sont
rejetés par le sol
on les traite avec beaucoup moins de
prudence que les charges explosives
on a tué onze membres deux des six il y
en a ici un autre là rien ne garantit
que la brigade de salaheddine pourra
garder la mainmise sur mazerat déjà ils
en ont perdu et gagné le contrôle à
trois reprises
c'est comme ça depuis des mois sur
plusieurs fronts en irak
une victoire se transforment en des
fêtes on avance ils ont recul manque de
troupes manque d'expérience ou selon ce
qu'affirmait le secrétaire américain à
la défense après la chute de ramadi
manque de volonté et de motivation de la
part des irakiens le problème qui ne
mine pas lui malgré l'entrée en scène de
la coalition il y à plus d'un an sa
capacité de ravitaillement ne
s'essouffle pas plus que sa capacité de
recrutement lui n'a pas d'avion de
chasse
ça m'empêche pas de semer la mort un
kamikaze
q - véhicule piégé à la fois des armes
principales de l'état islamique
ce sont des attentats suicides et des
voitures piégées ce sont des armes très
précise et redoutable
contrairement à nos armes qui elle l'est
une place à des races de l'homme au
calme au programme même si le général
maintient qu'il devrait en faire
beaucoup plus pour mettre en échec ce
fanatisme des combattants de leuilly les
chasseurs et les bombardiers de la
coalition avec toute leur technologie
puissance militaire ne sont peut-être
pas les armes les plus adéquats